[Música]
revista de prensa en France 24 para yo
le doy la bienvenida a mi compañera Alba
Santana Alba muy buenos días Buenos días
Andrés Alba vamos a abrir nuestra
revista de prensa en Francia la atención
entre los manifestantes y el estado
continúa medios europeos apuntan a que
se está investigando la muerte de un
hombre de 27 años en Marsella este fin
de semana tras recibir supuestamente un
disparo de un proyectil de goma por
parte de un policía cuéntanos Así es el
de esta publicación a francesa titula
disturbios urbanos se abre una
investigación por la muerte de un hombre
en Marsella Y es que un hombre iba en
patinete en esta ciudad en Marsella el 1
de Julio este sábado cuando de repente
cayó desplomado y fue trasladado al
hospital donde finalmente murió el
fiscal de Marsella asegura considera que
es muy probable que la muerte fuera
causado por el impacto violento de un
proyectil a flashball que lo llevó a una
parada cardíaca no murió directamente
por el impacto simplemente por el
arresto cardíaco de después y por ello
ahora se ha abierto una investigación
del departamento de Y es que este tipo
de proyectiles son los que utiliza la
policía francesa normalmente contra los
manifestantes Entonces ahora hay varias
preocupaciones sobre esta este suceso
porque podría provocar a más indignación
después de que los franceses en Marsella
salieran ya tres noches seguidas durante
el fin de semana la fiscalía aún no ha
conseguido determinar si esta víctima
habría participado directamente las
manifestaciones o simplemente estaba
transitando por la ciudad y bueno
seguimos con otra publicación esta vez
británica de telegraph Recuerda que
durante las protestas de ese día del
sábado la policía arrojó gas pimienta y
también hubo enfrentamientos entre los
manifestantes y la policía por lo que
dice según esta publicación que es muy
probable que también lanzarán este tipo
de proyectiles flashback estos
proyectiles normalmente no suelen ser
letales pero sí que son muy polémicos en
Francia porque sí que provocan heridas a
fuertes como de ojos e incluso
traumatismos fatales muy fuertes en la
cabeza independientemente de esto el
gobierno de macrón ahora está también
asegura que está intentando analizar
Cuáles son las causas más profundas de
estas manifestaciones por lo que con su
gabinete de gobierno están tratando lo
que los analistas acusan como el racismo
estructural en la sociedad francesa Pero
bueno desde el principio de estas
manifestaciones ya se han arrestado al
menos a 4000 a personas Alba vamos a
cambiar de tema ahora para pasar a Rusia
según medios anglosajones como the Card
o The New York Times el kremling estaría
planeando hacer un intercambio de
prisioneros con Estados Unidos así es
Andrés el kremlin según de Guardian
Aparentemente estaría abierto a dialogar
sobre este intercambio de prisioneros en
relación sobre todo con la detención de
un preso en concreto el periodista de
Wall Street journal
encerrado desde marzo y acusado
supuestamente de trabajar como espía
para Estados Unidos sería intercambiado
si se diera por a de una edad ciudadano
ruso bajo custodia estadounidense por
ciber crimen pescó el portavoz del
kremlin dijo al respeto cito
textualmente han habido varias tomas de
contacto sobre este tema pero deben
desarrollarse en completo silencio
Estados Unidos se habría quejado por no
tener acceso consular a grescovich antes
pero lo cierto es que también fue la
primera vez este lunes este lunes cuando
la embajada rusa en Estados Unidos tuvo
acceso a dunaeb desde 2021
si se da un intercambio de prisioneros
entre estos dos países no sería la
primera vez que pasa en diciembre ya se
intercambió la jugadora de
básquetner a cambio de Víctor y bueno
seguimos ahora con The New York Times
esta publicación estadounidense titula
el kremlin baraja un posible intercambio
de prisioneros tras la reunión de la
embajada de la embajadora de Estados
Unidos con Grace este artículo de New
York Times nos da un poco estas pistas
sobre cómo se llegaron a estas las
primeras negociaciones de intercambio de
prisioneros aunque también destaca que
el departamento de estado de Estados
Unidos ha dicho que deben ser totalmente
confidenciales en la embajadora de
Estados Unidos se habría reunido con
Grace y dijo que estaba en perfecta en
perfecto estado de salud y que sigue
fuerte pero bueno ese proceso todavía
podría tomar en meses claro un tema que
tiene en una puja diplomática a Rusia y
Estados Unidos Alba vamos a pasar a la
región donde el medio nicaragüense el
confidencial informa sobre la presunta
liberación del obispo Rolando José
Álvarez encarcelado en una celda máxima
de máxima seguridad tras negarse al
exilio en Estados Unidos Sí esta
publicación nicaragüense confidencial
titula Ortega excarcela monseñor Rolando
Álvarez de la modelo este periódico
nicaragüense asegura que el obispo de
matagalpa fue liberado este lunes a
petición del mismo gobierno de Daniel
Ortega Fuentes eclesiásticas Y
diplomáticas citadas en este artículo
aseguran que el obispo ya no estaría en
la prisión y que se encuentra bajo la
custodia de la conferencia episcopal el
recordemos que este religioso fue uno de
los pocos disidentes del gobierno de
Ortega que decidieron quedarse en el
país en lugar de exiliarse bueno fue
detenido en agosto de 2022 y tan solo un
día después de negarse a subirse a ese
avión que Nicaragua fletó a Estados
Unidos para aquellos que querían
exiliarse y les quitó la nacionalidad el
9 de febrero fue ese día después fue
encarcelado en una celda de máxima
seguridad y tras un juicio Express fue
condenado a 26 años de prisión por lo
que denominaron como conspiración contra
la soberanía nacional y propagación
también de noticias a falsas a su
destino ahora según las fuentes citadas
también en este artículo sería el exilio
Álvaro fue el primer Obispo el primer
religioso de Nicaragua que se considera
como preso político y ha recibido mucha
solidaridad internacional Alba y para
cerrar pasamos al mundo de la naturaleza
no tan alejado del nuestro investigación
científica ha probado que al igual que
los humanos los elefantes también les
gusta variar su menú para no cansarse
Así es esta publicación estadounidense
newswick titula los elefantes tienen una
forma muy humana de cenar y es que como
te puede pasar a ti mesa los elefantes
también se cansan de comer todos los
días a lo mismo un estudio realizado en
Kenia muestra que la dieta de los
elefantes no solo se basa en la
disponibilidad de los alimentos sino que
también se basaría en su estado de ánimo
un estudio publicado en Royal society
Open Science este estudio dice su dieta
depende de Quiénes son o del punto de
subida en el que están un punto de vista
muy existencialista por su parte el
estudio que analizó las heces de los
elefantes prueba que los animales comen
diferente también en función de la época
del año y solo al día diariamente comen
entre 50 y 100 a plantas diferentes les
gusta comer también hierba fresca como a
las personas nos gusta comer alimentos
frescos también Cuál es ese alimento que
usted no se cansa de comer no sabría
decir si estamos aquí diría arepita
paisa Vamos Bueno a mí las hamburguesas
Alba Muchísimas gracias por este repaso
por la prensa internacional Muchas
gracias Andrés